apparently they're at least going to
look into impeaching Joe Biden that's
McCarthy's move right here even though
they obviously don't have the Senate so
the guy's not going to be impeached okay
fine but I thought more interesting than
the decision to at least have this
inquiry was the media's immediate
reaction to this thing don't look at
that whatever you do don't look over
there check out this compilation you
know the president has been in politics
for a long time and I think as he would
say he's seen a lot of malarkey along
the way but this might take the cake
this is all smoke and no fire what a
waste of time and money have you seen
said evidence
no not a scintilla of evidence there is
not a shred of evidence that President
Joe Biden has engaged in wrongdoing no
business dealings of Hunter Biden's or
any ones was discussed in these
conversations smoke Malarkey shred
scintilla nothing nothing nothing
nothing I don't know maybe bank accounts
how did he become a multi-millionaire
while as a humble public servant all
these years why was his crackhead son
working at a Ukrainian Energy company
any of does any of this work for you
people but how about some of that
evidence I'm gonna have to read a little
of the evidence for you fine people this
is from the house oversight and
accountability committee uh Devin Archer
alone was aware of at least 20 times in
which then vice president spoke on
speakerphone with Hunter Biden's foreign
business associates Democrats would have
Americans believe that these phone calls
with Ben Vice President Biden were
simply to discuss the weather in
February 24 20 14 then Vice President
Joe Biden dined with oligarchs from
Russia and Kazakhstan who funneled
millions of dollars to Hunter Biden and
his business associates in April 2015
Ben Vice President Biden dined with
Hunter Biden's foreign business
associates including Ukrainian barisma
executive Vadim poharsky barismo was
then being investigated by Ukrainian
prosecutor General Victor shoken for
corruption in 2015 then Vice President
Biden hosted Hunter Biden and Devon
Archer and other business associates at
the official residence of the vice
president the topic of discussion was
filling the top seat at the United
Nations the kazakhstani government
official who wanted the U.N position
attended both dinners at Cafe Milano
within Vice President Biden you know we
have a ton more here but let's just
let's just come back to me because I
think people broadly get the point Joe
Biden has repeatedly said he never
discussed business with his son
Carol what kind of father would that
make him at the very least
right a loving father who absolutely
discussed business with his son um what
about the the text from Hunter to his
sister saying I'm not going to make you
give me give me a half your salary like
like pop does
um Hunter never gets asked about any of
this how come none of them get asked
about this there's no evidence because
nobody has looked for any of the
evidence nobody has asked any of the
questions that you know lead to finding
the evidence I think the things that you
have presented are is evidence but if
people need more they can simply ask
questions because I've last heard that
that's what journalists are supposed to
do I get that it's a Democrat so they
don't do it for them but maybe they
should start right Democrat privilege
but Josh if they want evidence wouldn't
the simple thing and it seems like they
have it just be looking at bank accounts
just be looking at Hunter Biden bank
accounts and Joe Biden family bank
accounts and go where did all of this
money come how how is it that Joe Biden
is worth 20 or 30 or more million
dollars how did Hunter Biden with no
skills get this job at this thing on top
of the fact that he's an artist which
the easiest you know quote-unquote
artist the easiest way to money launder
is have a crackhead use a crayon and
then give him a ton of money pardon
my French
yeah no I I mean I as we see all the
time in politics you know these people
that serve in Washington DC in the swamp
for 30 40 50 plus years in the case of
Joe Biden they somehow managed to get
off of Lee rich off of it you know you
know funny how that works right but part
of the reason why Ken McCarthy had to do
this is that the Administration has been
shall we say less than forthcoming when
it comes to trying to to suss out many
of the details pertaining to these
overseas dealings